-Our next guest
is an Emmy-nominated actor
and comedian as well as
the creator and star
of the critically acclaimed
series, "Ramy."
The entire third season
is streaming now on Hulu.
Please welcome back to the show
Ramy Youssef, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Ramy.
-Dude.
-I am so happy
to have you here in person.
-I know.
In person's amazing.
-You were, I guess, here
maybe three, four years ago
when the first season
of your show was out.
-Yeah.
-And somehow you've managed to,
in a very hard time
to make television,
made two more seasons.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
Yeah, it was --
You guys did it, too.
We did one of these on Zoom...
-Yep.
-...which was also great.
But, yeah,
seeing you in person is like --
-It's a lot nicer.
-I know. I hugged you,
and I was like, I remembered
the time we all had hope.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-There used to be so much hope.
-Yeah.
-I've been, like --
You know, I was telling you,
too, back there,
I've been thinking about
just how much I can't trust my
feelings these last few years.
-How's that?
-Like, you know, I don't think
I trust what's going on
in my head anymore.
And even looking out right now,
and it's like some people
are wearing masks, some aren't,
and it scares me.
What do they know that...?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-'Cause I'm starting to think,
you know, I'm at that point now
where I see someone with a mask,
and, you know...
-It's interesting.
I feel like people broke
two different ways,
and I'm very much like you.
I feel like some people
are like, "I know exactly where
the pandemic's at, at all times,
whatever I think is right."
-Yes.
-Whereas I'm
constantly thinking,
"I might be doing this wrong."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I realized
that I can't trust myself
'cause I remember
the first mask I saw.
Remember the first one?
-Yep.
-Like, early.
I remember that guy,
just seeing him at
the supermarket, I'm like,
"Oh, look at this guy."
[ Laughter ]
It was like, "Okay, buddy.
Someone's been on YouTube."
[ Laughter ]
"You're gonna go back to your
bunker, like, what's going on."
And then, two weeks later...
[ Laughter ]
I saw a guy without a mask,
and I was like,
"Whoa.
Look who hates Black people."
[ Laughter ]
"Like, this guy does not care
about the country."
Immediately, I was like, "Oh,
that happened in two weeks."
-Yeah.
-Everything changed.
I don't trust myself anymore.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Rarely do you go from
the first part to the second
part in just two weeks.
-Two weeks.
-Usually takes years
to get there.
-Oh, man, I'm just a new person,
immediately.
-One of my favorite things about
your show is, it's very funny,
but there's also a really great
narrative thrust to the show.
And with that in mind, I don't
want to give anything away.
-Yeah.
-Because the end of season 2
sort of left Ramy --
And he was just thriving.
Just doing great.
And then there's --
I will only say,
there's a bit of a time jump.
Is it --
What would you tell people
before they go into season 3?
-You know, I think the show --
the most interesting part
about it, to me, has always been
just this idea
of trying to be with someone
who wants a spiritual life.
I think it's something that
a lot of people can relate to,
and it's not something
that we see in a serious way.
You know, it's obviously
a comedy, so we're finding
the funny that's in it,
but just the serious pursuit.
And I think he's always in this
battle between his higher self
and his lower self,
but we really kind of go into
this one where he's like,
"You know what?
Maybe I just am my lower self,"
and he kind of believes that
for a while.
And so we're seeing
this crisis of faith.
-There's a very funny scene
about Christmas,
and this is based on your own
personal history.
But can we show the clip first
and then discuss?
-Yeah.
-Let's take a look.
-Our traditions
have a lot in common.
-Yeah, I've always felt that.
That we share this deep
Christmaslessness, you know?
-Huh?
-Like not celebrating Christmas,
right?
Like, the whole country --
this whole country's, like,
worshipping Santa,
and we're like,
"No, I don't think something --
This doesn't feel right."
You know?
-Hmm.
-I remember being
in kindergarten,
everyone's talking about Santa.
I look over at this kid, Ari,
and I'm like,
"Dude, we know the truth.
We know this is just,
like, a capitalist [bleep] lie."
[ Laughter ]
-Christmaslessness,
was this something that you
found common cause with other
kids in school growing up?
-Oh, this was deep.
Me and my Jewish friends,
we were the only ones
who knew the truth.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you keep it to yourself?
-Well, you try,
but then you say something,
and then you get in trouble.
And then they're like,
"What are you doing?"
"I'm telling the truth."
And it's so wild, like,
this feeling of being a kid
and realizing you're just
surrounded by lies.
Like, I remember watching,
even TV, I saw a clip as a child
of Bill Clinton, and he's on TV,
and he's like,
"Santa's coming to your homes.
I hope he brings you
nice gifts."
And I was like, in that moment,
I was like,
"I will never trust
this government."
[ Laughter ]
Ever. I mean, that's the guy
we're supposed to trust?
I'm supposed to believe these
people about Guantanamo?
Like, this is --
it's dark, you know?
And you really --
Yeah, you're a child,
and you know about the Christmas
industrial complex.
[ Laughter ]
It's damaging.
-Is it fun in the writers' room
when you realize that you can --
I mean, again,
so much of the show, I imagine,
is pulled
from personal experiences,
but it must be so great to know
that you can write
a Christmaslessness monologue
and get to perform it
as an adult.
Just must be the best.
-No, it's cathartic in that way.
I mean, and a lot of it, like,
I'll find on stage
and then bring it in,
and then that's where
it's really fun kind of
having a group of people
who've all experienced it.
-There's a great -- obviously,
a great element of the show,
are the people
who play your parents.
You have parents
in real life, as well.
How do they feel about the show?
What is their feedback?
-You know, they, um --
You know, they don't --
they don't like the sex scenes,
which is, like --
-Fair.
-Yeah.
And it's your parents.
They don't want to see --
I tell them it's a stunt guy.
[ Laughter ]
I tried to tell -- I'm like,
even with the sex stuff,
I'm like, "Look, I promise,
my next role, no sex,
like, just violence."
[ Laughter ]
"Like, I'll just kill people."
And they're like,
"Oh, thank God."
[ Laughter ]
-I will say, while it might
be disappointing
when your parents say,
"We don't like the sex scenes,"
the alternative would be worse,
right?
If they were like,
"Our favorite part..."
[ Laughter ]
-No, yeah, that'd be, like --
My dad, though,
will give me notes about --
like, he doesn't like that,
and then he'll just talk to me
about the lighting
for like an hour.
-Really?
-Yeah, he'll be like,
"You got to look at the lighting
in a couple of these scenes.
I'd like to see progress
next season."
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Does he have a background
in lighting?
-Uh, no.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
He's just learning by watching?
-There's no lighting
in our family.
Like, we're kind of
a dimly lit family, actually.
We try to save money
on the electric bill.
Most of my life was,
"Turn off that light."
-The weird thing is --
it is a beautifully shot show.
And it is funny that your dad
would find a way
to criticize that.
I mean --
-Well, he's a father.
He just -- He wants
the lighting to get better.
-Yeah, that's all.
-And I think that's all it is.
-He's like,
"Look, the lighting's fine."
-[ Laughs ]
"It's great where it is,
but I want to push you
to take it to the next level."
-I don't want you to settle on
the current lighting situation.
-Yeah, exactly.
-I'm wondering, you know, again,
we're talking about how much,
you know,
your life inspires the show.
One decision you made early on
is, being an actor named Ramy
who called the show "Ramy" and
plays a character named Ramy.
Do you ever regret that?
[ Laughter ]
-Every single day.
Like, every -- every single day,
I'm like, "There's so many
other names
that we could have picked."
And it's funny,
because I grew up --
Part of it was,
I wanted to have my name,
you know, and not just
'cause it was me,
but because the industry
that came before me,
it was anyone
who had an Arab name,
they changed their name
in order to blend in.
-Right.
-If your name was Muhammad,
you'd want to say you were Mike.
You know,
you'd try to find something.
And so I was like, "Yeah,
I want to have an Arab name."
But now -- yeah, now we're like
three seasons in,
we can't change the name.
Now I'm like, "Well,
maybe I'll change my name."
Like, I might, in real life,
just -- I might just go --
like, maybe I'm just Robert now.
-Yeah.
So, the show's still "Ramy,"
but then you tell people,
you're like, "That's not me."
-Yeah, and I made progress.
I made it in Hollywood as an
Arab, but now I'm Robert.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
That's the thing you would prove
to everybody.
You're like, "I owned it."
-It can be done.
-Until I made it,
and now I want to be Robert.
-Now I'm Robert. Yeah, yeah.
It's been done.
-Well, I hope you stick
with Ramy.
I think we all prefer the Ramy,
having a little Ramy
in our lives,
both on screen and off.
It's really a fantastic --
We were talking backstage.
I've watched the first
couple episodes of season 3.
It's great.
It's always been great.
And it's so lovely to have you
here in person.
-Thank you, man.
Thanks, dude.
Thank you, thank you.
-Ramy Youssef, everybody.
The third season of "Ramy"
is streaming now on Hulu.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."